[Musique]
carte ils sont fâchés matin jeudi on
t'envoie au cimetière si c'est fragile
j'appelle toujours mes gars sur coma
matraques plus gros calibres attention
bélé bélé bélé bélé tiff la sauce
blanche n'est pas dans mon great salade
faut maintenant nous représente et aux
arcs en ciel
j'enlève des caleçons pas l'esprit file
16 9 1 9 3 9
oumé braga c'est à débattre 957
bkc s'était alors ce qui se passe les
mecs on essaie de faire un clip positif
montré que la banlieue c'est pas juste
de la violence entre les mecs aussi de
la la tendresse des câlins et bisous
ménat qui jouent pas le jeu là toi toi
là non toi plutôt la whey toi jouent pas
le jeu mon pote
alors on se met dedans on se lâche et on
est parti on est des hommes on s'aime on
est en banlieue on peut le faire
allez on y va les gars on y va 20h03
nafta
oumé brega si tu avais pas
9 5 7 5 7 7 5
obligation même si c'était plus
[Musique]